I think it's a super valid question
everything you're asking me is a super
valid question I agree that's why I'm
asking
them now stop wasting my time hey hey
hey hey hey we need some merch but if it
was that sever wouldn't you already feel
pain wouldn't you already have bruises
on your face I mean you say that he
punched you in the face but where are
the
[__]
[__] so if you aren where
um Trevor bow is a pitcher in Major
League Baseball and he got Accused by a
lady of battery all kinds of different
things it was litigating Court he lost a
lot as a result but he vly denied any
allegations and recently came out with
some of this stuff next victim star
pitcher for the Dodgers a text lindsy
Hill sent to a friend before she ever
even met me what should I steal she
asked another in reference to visiting
my house for the first time the answer
take his money so how might that work
I'm going to his house Wednesday she
said I already have my hooks in you know
how I roll then after the first time we
met net worth is 51 mil she said she
better secure the bag was the response
but but how was she going to do that
need daddy to choke me out she said
being an absolute [__] to try to get in
on his 51 million read another
text Hey listen that gold digger group
go crazy they know they know they know
these texts are crazy and anyone says
why would they
lie cuz they
can I already got my hooks in she's
convinced she going to get the money for
them and the other women in the group
chat know this behavior and are
encouraging and Ting on meaning like
they might be engaging in this [__] too
with other athletes I need daddy to
choke me out this just sound like hey
Let's Get Physical in bed so I can next
day say that I was beaten up I don't
know where this going going so let's
find out super Speedy announcement our
Discord is up a lot of political
discussions going on all about all kinds
of stuff also people gaming CH chatting
about different Abba and preach topics
as well as anything under the Sun so
check the link in the description below
for that then after the second time we
met former Padre's pitcher Jacob Nicks
told her you got to get this bag I'll
give you 50,000 Lindsay replied her AA
sponsor asked her at one point do you
feel a tiny bit guilty not really she
replied since then her legal team has
approached me multiple times about
coming to a financial settlement
but as I have done since day one I
refused to pay her even a single scent
uh in August of 2021 Lindsay Hills
claims were heard in court and during
those legal proceedings critical
information was deliberately and
unlawfully concealed from me and my
legal team uh information like this
video which was taken by Lindsay Hill
herself the morning after she claimed
she was brutally attacked emotionally
traumatized and desperate to get away
from me and now we have the metadata so
there can be no dispute uh it was taken
mere minutes before she left my
house I'm so glad that a lot of evil
people are so [__] stupid that they
sell snitch with these kinds of
videos like even if you were one of her
supporters and said oh my God believe
women like there's just noing way that a
girl claims she was getting her ass
beaten and she take a video like that
the morning before she leave the dude's
place like even they got to look at this
and be like
this [__] is lying yeah I think you got
to kind of look at it like that
no can anybody really look at this and
say I believe her when you show them
that and you go believer and you show
them that they like well I'd rather have
one guy that's not guilty than letting
other guys that are actually guilty free
so I'm going to believe all women that's
what they say smirking at the camera
without a care in the world or any marks
on her face I think it paints a pretty
clear picture of what actually happened
the evening of May 15 15 and why the
video was originally concealed from us
yeah I mean if you were choking her you
didn't do it properly bro like that
looks like the softest daintiest sex
that has ever happened all I'm trying to
say is you don't leave your place
bruised up and beaten you didn't really
[__] her
properly hey kids I think it's a good
time to start turning off the
video
all right I'm just play this channel was
never meant for kids all right let's
just keep watching after hearing the
evidence available to her judge Diana
gold saltman found that Lindsey Hill had
misled the court she found her claims to
be materially misleading uh she denied
her request for a domestic vience
restraining order and she found that no
sexual or non-consensual conduct took
place now some of you might not know
about restraining order hearings I know
I didn't but uh I've since learned that
uh it's extremely rare for request for a
restraining order to be denied because
the standard of proof that you need to
obtain one is extremely low so you can
make of that what you will the fact is I
was never arrested I was never charged
with a crime and I won the only legal
proceeding that took place without my
side of the story even being heard so I
sued her which prompted her to counter
sue me quite frankly regardless of the
outcome in court I've paid significantly
more in legal fees and Lindsay Hill
could ever pay me in her entire life and
I knew that would be the case going in
but the lawsuit was never about the
money for me it was the only way for me
to obtain critical information to clear
my name uh the discovery process in that
lawsuit recently concluded at which
point uh Lindsay Hill's legal team again
came to us with another proposal to
resolve the case uh this time however
they weren't seeking any money from me
having received uh much of the
information that had been hidden from us
a small portion of which I've referenced
here um I was willing to agree to the
terms proposed both part parties would
drop their respective lawsuits and nah
nah nah cuz at this point he lost way
too
much now you just got to drop it oh I
got the information I got just got to
drop it oh I'll drop I'll drop my thing
you drop your thing and everything is
all good we going to go scad our own
ways yo that's [__] why is that [__]
up it's [__] because you know you lied
and now I have the information that I
know you lied and now you're like oh no
let's just agree to just just let's drop
it
yeah I'm all for you know you need to
pay some [__] but I understand why they
would go that way but that's [__] up
it's [__] up because the people you
went out there and you did all these
claims and allegations I lost so many
things without I'm not even talking
about legal feel fees and stuff I lost
so much stuff
right and now I could prove that you lie
and it was a scheme and you can just
watch just walk off freely everything is
all good that hurts me that's why I'm
like oh man that that's [__] up but he
was he it was just a lawsuit he couldn't
do anything I know I I know it's just
what I'm saying is I'm not my my my my
my bur is not so much that no you should
do something and this like that it's
just ah man it's [__] up that I have
to spend all that money all that cash to
prove that I was and I was not wrong but
you you just scattle way oops I'mma do
it again later on that's and to me
that's [__] up I'm not saying that's
why you don't fight somebody who has
nothing to lose
when you have everything and someone
with nothing to lose challenges you
there's no reason because if you win you
gain nothing and you probably lose in
the process you take damage Financial
otherwise and if you lose then they gain
everything so this just one of those
things where you can't win so he cut his
losses he listened to his lawyers who
said there's no point in going through
with this and he did the smart thing he
did the smart thing but it's just it's
just it's just frustrating you know what
I mean like it's frustrating that you
did all this [__] it was all the scheme
you're the bad guy MH and then you just
la la la la la you're cute you're
talking about yo privilege don't exist
for them it does it really does but
hopefully this is the last time I have
to do so as I'd prefer to just remain
focused on doing my job uh winning
baseball games and entertaining fans
around the world so today I'm happy to
be moving on with my life good and honly
that's the best gift possible yeah cuz
there's no amount of restitution that
can fix what happened in the past uh but
at the very least if you cleared the air
and you've made everything public and
you could actually move on then that's
like the best thing possible cuz
otherwise you're just going to stay
angry and there's no amount of Revenge
that's going to fix that um but she did
an interview recently with Sarah
Gonzalez and I want to see that or we
get to hear her side so I want to read
some of these texts from you to a friend
between the two of you before you met
Trevor this one next victim star pitcher
for the Dodgers okay victim is an
interesting choice of words I'm I'm
going to allow you a chance to explain
yourself but after you agreed to meet
you asked your friend what should what
you should steal your friend answered
his money uh he says another one from
you to a friend I'm going to his house
Wednesday I already have my hooks in you
know how I roll here's some more after
you and Trevor met up net worth is 51
million to which your friend responds
[__] you better secure that bag your
text need daddy to choke me out being an
absolute [__] to try to get in on his
51 million you say this wasn't a setup
how can you expect anyone to believe
that that's a great question I really
appreciate you having me on to even have
this conversation um obviously there's a
lot going on around this so I really
appreciate uh people who are asking
questions about it um the first thing I
want to say is you know I think that
Trevor did this intentionally with the
text messages and how he framed this
video um there's several things in it
that are not correct um and I just want
to start out by saying you know those
it's so valid for people to question
those text messages but the root of the
answer the question what the [__] is
this PR response just answer the
question that's someone talking answer
the goddamn question this response is
the lanest here is that he is presenting
this as one conversation when in reality
he had thousands of message messages to
choose from took those made it look
sequential which it was not um there is
no combined screenshot of those things
going on okay they're not
sequential just the thing what should
you steal my girl just
that sequential or not those things were
said let's see what she says I'm curious
I don't know I've never watched
this you're saying that it's misleading
because you did you're admitting that
you did talk about rough sex and wanting
rough you did talk about uh he him
needing to choke you out you did talk
about stealing his money but it's
misleading because he put them together
in the same video as if you had said it
in the same conversation when in fact it
was separate conversations correct that
that's what why it's misleading correct
and as well as not showing you know the
messages that occurred after where it
discusses it strictly in the term of you
know being a baseball wife or something
like that or something like that okay
I'm I'm just curious if you know like
the statistical likelihood of you
texting your friend premeditated texts
saying you wanted him to choke you out
and steal his money take his money and
him actually choking you out and those
two things not being related that's my
girl go in it's a really really valid
question and like I said I think you
would need to look through each
conversation those were handpicked um
but I can like I said last night
completely own the fact that those were
Sarah's face looks like you this horse
lying
yeah shar's looking at the camera like
squinting and it a't cuz she can't see
yeah are you she like she has a
permanent really
[__] under really that's what you going
to say come on bro so you said in court
that he sexually assaulted you on two
different encounters and you say the
first time that you you say he choked
you unconscious clearly the insinuation
is you didn't like it cuz now you're
calling it an assault but why did you
make the drive back to LA to meet back
up with him a second time if this man
had just assaulted you by your own
account it's a really good question I
phrased it anded um in the past is that
uh I was so embarrassed by the first
encounter um that I felt something you
know deep in me to go and take the power
back and to be better and to be what he
wanted in in a sense um and so I
don't well I'm not putting that dollar
in that jar what the [__] did she just
say power back after you get power back
all right G g g g g g Okay g g g g oh my
God I'm lying again g g g gang it's me
my [__] and all my friends g g g am I
gold
dier hell yeah am I here for the
dollar hell yeah that's what it is I
maybe I'm unaware am I everything you
wish you didn't see in a nightmare
everybody yeah that's what it is okay
with the song but I don't know there's
been a lot of you know through all the
processes um expert witness experts on
the psychology of what happens when you
are a XYZ uh but there was something in
me that felt like I needed to make it
better in a sense okay um but you texted
Trevor before you met him telling him
you liked rough Then you texted him
after your first sexual encounter with
him which you now call an assult and
according to court records you told him
after that sexual encounter that you had
quote never been more turned on in your
life that's not really something oh yo
whose girl is this whose girl is this
who are you girlfriend [__] you are a
[__] asking the right questions getting
the tea and the bag and everything juicy
who are you
okay
okay let's go Sarah Sarah
Gonzalez should retitled this video
Sarah Gonzalez interviews lying [__] yo
Sarah who are Sarah gonz I need to frame
that picture up I'm I'mma have a frame
of your picture like this all right
let's see this let's keep going oh my
God we we should no no we going to have
we going to have merch we need we need
Zar Gonzalez mer let's keep going that's
not really something that someone says
when they were just
a I think it's a super valid question
everything you're asking me is a super
valid question I agree that's why I'm
asking
them now stop oing my time minut hey hey
hey hey hey hey we need some merch we
need some
merch that was crazy we need to merch
she said stop with the pr I know I I
know it's a valid question answer the
question fluffy kid get on that [__]
look at that face yo I zoom zoom in on
that
face when I was a kid all this time I
wish so like I wish I wish that
superheroes exist and then Sarah
appeared go let's go and for everybody's
asking me about the editor contest it's
still going on you can make unlimited
amount of entries up until the end of
October after that point we're going to
be selecting the people who are going to
be mov on to phase too the goal with
this so I make it clear for everyone is
to find an editor who can be autonomous
who can work remotely and manage the
things find the right kind of Clips so
the things that we're looking for in an
editor are one creativity when it comes
to the editing process two good clip
selection and what constitute good clip
selection sometimes it's a matter of
like making sure you get enough of us
and not just the content we're reacting
to but also finding clips that people
want to watch we want to be sure that
you understand the platforms that you're
editing and posting on and that you can
see a clip see that it's going to be
good content and then upload it to the
right spot so that people do want to
click on those and so you know be smart
about your clip selection be good about
your editing you know if you want to add
in pizaz to make the clip more
interesting definitely do that and like
I said we're not limiting the amount of
entries you can make from a single uh
channel that you create for this contest
so do this much use the hashtag Abba and
preach video contest whether you do the
n or a ND doesn't matter um yeah that's
it we want to see you guys like I said
it's a full-time job uh full fully
remote and it pays a full-time salary so
yeah totally and I think that I'm not um
you know that's what expert Witnesses
are for in court in terms of the
psychology behind that in responses to
abuse and things like that um but like I
said I was just trying to make it be
make myself feel better about myself
after what had happened the first time
um and you know after the first time I
left without any markings on my body my
face was fine I could go to work um and
I thought that the first time
would be the second time excuse me would
be like the first time minus the things
I told him I was not comfortable with
yeah so you mentioned the markings on
your body um I want to play a portion of
his video in which he plays a I would
say interesting video of you in his bed
watch this video which was taken by
Lindsay hillers s the morning after she
claimed she was brutally attacked
emotionally traumatized and desperate to
get away from me and now we have the
metadata so there can be no dispute uh
it was taken mere minutes before she
left my house on the morning of May 16th
201 21 Lindsay I think there are a lot
of sexual assault survivors who would
say you don't look traumatized there and
you don't look beaten and this is
allegedly after you say that he brutally
attacked you and you had bruises all
over your body you had bruises all over
your face I don't see any bruises there
and I certainly don't see a woman who's
just been traumatized by something
horrible again super valid um I think
that I woke up that morning and the best
way to explain that video is I hadn't
seen my entire body yet I had no idea
what had happened and considering you
know I was unconscious for most of it I
had no idea what had happened to my full
body but if it was that severe wouldn't
you already feel pain wouldn't you
already have bruises on your face I mean
you say that he punched you in the face
but where are
the
[__]
[__] SS Gonzalez is a dawn I'm stopping
the video there
why Wow all I'll say is
this I'm at peace with it thing is
people
lie nobody should be believed not
children not adults not men not women
not anything else you just got to wait
for facts and evidence to come up and go
from there but people [__]
lie that's all it comes down to all I
don't have to make a big Pro there's no
profound conclusion people
lie
anything else no I think Sarah Gonzalez
didn't all the heavy
lifting o we that's how you supposed to
ask questions let's go
Sarah